The first part here was easy.
We want digits to be the same length as the number of letters,
because we want to substitute them one for one--123 for ABC or whatever.
We want to ask itertools.permutations to take permutations of the letters taken n at a time
where n is the number of letters, the length of the letters. That part's easy.
This part's a little bit more complicated--how do we find the letters.
Here's what I did. I used the regular expression, the "re" module.
I used the findall function so that says find all letters from A to Z,
and I didn't specify here capitals before.
My interpretation and the general rules for this type of cryptarithmetic problems
is that they should be capitals, but if you allow lowercase as well, that's fine.
Find them all within the formula, make a set of those, because if a letter
occurs more than once we don't want multiple versions of it.
We just want individual ones.
Then join them together into a string.
Now, I should say that I snuck in one piece of code here that you haven't seen before
that may seem wild at first. That's the very first line.
It says from future import division.
That seems pretty amazing. Wow. Python has a built-in time machine.
What does it mean to import division from the future?